Now that the user had logged in to
a client work station, Venus will establish an
RPC session, on behalf of the client. And
in order to establish the RPC session, the
following message exchange is going to happen. And this
is what is called the bind operation between
the client and the server. So what Venus
is going to do is send the client identity and
an encrypted cipher. The client identity, as I mentioned earlier, in
private keycryptal systems, you have to send it in clear text so that the server
knows the identity of the client and in order to establish a new
RPC session, Venus will use the secret token as the
client identity. And it will use the HKC, the handshake
key for the client that was contained in the clear token data structure
that was given back to the work station by the server as part of executing
the log in process. That is the key that will be used for encrypting
the starting message for the RPC session
establishment. Now what exactly is the massage that
is being sent. Well all there is sent for initiating this RPC session
establishment, is a random number which is new for each RPC session that Venus
is establishing on behalf of this client. Every time it wants to establish a new
RPC session within a login session, it creates a new random number and
encrypts it using the handshake key. That's
the cipher text. And the secret token
is the client ID, and that's the message that goes from virtue to vice, the
server. So when this message arrives at the server, how will the server decrypt
this message? Well, the client ID is
the secret token. Recall that the secret token
is nothing but an encryption of the clear token,
with a key that is known only to the
server, and therefore, what the server can do is
take the secret token, decrypt it using the key that
it has and once it decrypts it, it gets
this clear token data structure and from the clear token
data structure, it can say well what is the
key that is contained in this clear token data structure,
take the key and decrypt this message. Cause, that key is HKC, and that
is how the server can get the message that has been sent as the initiation
of the RPC session. So in particular, what the server has gotten now is
the random number that was sent to it by Venus Xr. Now what the server does,
is it takes this random number, increments it by 1, and also adds a new random
number, Yr, and that is a message that it is going to send back to the client.
It has to encrypt this message of course,
because its going on the wire, which is insecure.
So it's going to encrypt it using a
key, a handshake key which we'll call HKS and
by design, HKC and HKS are exactly the same. So in other words, whatever is the
handshake key that has been given to the
client in the clear token, is the same handshake
key that the server is going to use
to communicate information back to the client as
well. So, it encrypts this message with this
handshake key and sends it over to the client.
So what is the purpose of this message?
When this message comes over to the client,
the client can decrypt this message. How? It's
going to use HKC which is the handshake key
that it knows will be used by a genuine server to encode the message and send it
to the client, and so it can use
HKC to decrypt this message and once it decrypts
this message, it gets these two numbers. There's Xr
plus 1, that is the original random number that this guy sent over to the server
incremented by 1. Now what is the purpose served by this
number, Xr plus 1. It actually establishes to the client that the
server is genuine. Anybody could replay a message
that they see on the wire, but for this message to have the right content, what
the client is expecting is that the response that the client is going to get for
the original message that was initiating the RPC
session. is that the response from the server
is going to contain a number that is 1
greater than the random number that it sent
the server in the first place. So, if this number, Xr plus 1, is what the
client was expecting, then it establishes that the
server is genuine. So this goes back to
what I said about authentication of the server.
That is one of the challenges that the
[INAUDIBLE] system has. This is the way the
virtue workstation, the Venus process on the virtue workstation
on behalf of the client can establish the
genuineness of the server that this workstation is talking
to. Or in other words, it's not a
Trojan Horse that is sending this message. But it
is genuine server that is sending this message
because this field is exactly what Venus expected it
to be. Now what is this number? This is
another random number that the server is sending as
part of this message. Why is it sending
this random number? It'll become clear in the
next set of communication that's going on between
Venus and Vice. Now once Venus has extracted
this Yr from this message, what it is going to do is it is
going to increment it by 1 and take that as a message, Yr plus 1, as a message,
encrypt it using the handshake key, and send
it over to this server. And when the
server decrypts this message and extracts this field,
it'll see whether this field is what it
is expecting it to be. What the server is expecting is that this will be Yr
plus 1. And if the client is genuine,
then the client would've been able to extract Yr
from this response that came from the server and generate Yr plus 1
and send it over to the server. So in other words, this message coming to the
server is establishing the genuineness of the
client, because this original message that we
saw could have been just a replay,
meaning somebody sniffed the network, got a hold
of this packet, and replayed it. But if
they replayed it, then they would not have the
key, and they would not have been able
to decrypt this message. So the fact that the
client was able to decrypt this message, extract
Yr increment it and send a new message that
contains Yr plus 1 to the server is
authenticating to the server that the client is genuine.
Just as this message established to the
client that the server is genuine, similarly, this
message coming from the client to the
server is establishing to the server that the
client is genuine. And this pair of
communication that you are seeing is also avoiding
replay attack either from the client to the
server or from the server to the client.
In both directions, we're avoiding it by
this trick of generating a new random number.
For establishing an RPC session and communicating it
back and forth between the client and server.